merci la palette à monsieur claude de
ganay merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre au mois de
mai dernier je mettais en garde le
précédent gouvernement contre les
conséquences de sa politique énergétique
désastreuse s'entêtant dans l'erreur
celui ci a publié en catimini le 27
octobre dernier un décret exigeant d'edf
un plan de démantèlement de la filière
nucléaire
pour atteindre l'objectif de 50% d'ici
monsieur le premier ministre fermer des
centrales nucléaires sûres et
opérationnelle est un non sens
économique
un désastre industriel est une farce
environnemental non sens économique car
vous dilapidez ainsi le fruit de
précieuses investissement qui
garantissent aujourd'hui aux
consommateurs français une électricité
parmi les moins chers d'europe
oser leur dire que les factures
d'électricité vont augmenter désastre
industriel car vous sacrifier un fleuron
technologique français et condamné des
territoires ruraux dont l'activité
économique est intimement liée aux
industries qui s'y trouvent encore une
fois ce sont les zones rurales qui
paient le prix de vos errements
politiques aux et leur dire que les
emplois détruits ne pourront évidemment
pas être compensée farce
environnementale enfin car dans un délai
aussi court la transition énergétique ne
se fera pas à consommation constante
d'électricité il faudrait produire 18
d'ici huit ans 133 térawatts heures
supplémentaires pour compenser les
fermetures de réacteurs nucléaires
ce qui représente la bagatelle de trente
mille éolienne ou un milliard trois cent
trente millions de mètres carrés de
panneaux solaires vous devrez soit
importé de l'électricité alors que nous
en exportons et cette électricité ne
sera pas issu d'énergies renouvelables
soit il vous faudra ouvrir des centrales
à combustibles fossiles osé dire la
vérité sur la transition énergétique
telle que vous la concevez monsieur le
premier ministre si vous maintenez ce
choix pouvez vous nous dire
selon quels critères seront fermées dès
son graal la parole et à mesure en bray
vallini secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations
avec le parlement merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député je vais
vous répondre précisément sur la
fermeture envisagée de la centrale de
fessenheim qui est évidemment la
fermeture dont on parle le plus cette
fermeture a été enclenchée depuis
octobre 2015 et df étudie l'unique
hypothèse de fermeture nationale pour se
conformer à votre transition énergétique
madame royal a demandé à edf de déposer
la demande de retrait de l'autorisation
d'exploiter des deux réacteurs de la
centrale de telle sorte que le décret
d'abrogation son prix dans les mois qui
viennent les discussions à kiev se passe
bien monsieur le député elles ont permis
de définir conjointement une formule de
calcul de l'indemnisation qui fait
l'objet d'un accord de principe
il est prévu que l'indemnité soit versé
en plusieurs étapes avec une première
étape à 100 millions d'euros le comité
central d'entreprise ddfc le 14
septembre dernier pour examiner le sujet
et a demandé des éléments d'expertisé
complémentaires le conseil
d'administration lui se réunira
prochainement le processus des
consultations des instances et des fdf
est donc engagée fessenheim monsieur le
député la centrale la plus ancienne de
france elle aura 40 ans en 2017
ainsi grâce à sa fermeture et des va
vous faire économiser le fonctionnement
de la centrale et les investissements
qui auraient été nécessaires à une
éventuelle prolongation
l'argent ainsi économisé écoutez bien
mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'argent ainsi économisé pourra servir à
la prolongation d'autres réacteurs
nucléaires et au développement des
énergies renouvelables
fessenheim peut devenir ainsi eu des
manques tellement exemplaire il a des
opportunités industrielles à saisir pour
le démantèlement de centrales à conduire
partout dans le monde
ces discussions s'inscrivent donc dans
le cadre du dialogue global sur le
projet industriel économique bdf
nous accompagnons et df au service de
l'indépendance énergétique de la
transition énergétique et de la
performance énergétique
merci